The solar eclipse is happening today
there's a lot of ways that the solar eclipse might affect you
as it represents new beginnings
different star signs and birthdays are supposed to have different reactions
So of course if you're single or in a relationship
changes in your love life can mean very different things
If there's anything that has the potential to mix things up
I'd say it's an eclipse
whether you're single or in a relationship
expect positive changes in your love life
if you're single
this could mean meeting someone new when you least expect it
or have better conversations with a romantic partner
and or experience closer connections
in general
moving over to if you're already in a relationship
you should expect less friction in the relationship
a more romantic connection with your partner or simply having more engaged
meaningful conversations
I hope you enjoy watching the solar eclipse today
and don't forget to wear productive glasses
you don't wanna hurt your retinas
since the solar eclipse is all about new beginnings
be on the lookout for all these positive changes in your life.